e
[Applause]
[Music
] fifa stated that it will not accept
inappropriate behavior from
spectators and labeled this cry as
homophobic but how did this cry start it
has roots in american football yes
in monterrey in the 80s
according to the american football association
This city's children's club used to say
at the time of the kick and if football would then
spread to the fans
of Atlas in the Jalisco stadium on
May 1, 1999, where the first
to receive it would be the former goalkeeper of the
Mexican team,
Oswaldo Sánchez.  Much because of this cry,
it began to be heard in
international competitions and it was in the
2014 World Cup in Brazil when Fifa decided to take
forceful measures against this tradition
from there if I speak of sanctions such as
fines playing behind closed doors losing
points in a tournament or even the  expulsion
from a 2015 world cup to date the
mexican soccer federation has been
sanctioned by fifa 14 times
we communicated with  adolfo ríos ex
goalkeeper of the tri and this is what he told us
later a
wrong concept of ingrid was created because it is not a
situation of insulting someone I
see it as a feeling of not being
able to in any way because they are
players at  command of the field and that what
happens in the stands does not have to
affect it. I think that
other measures should be taken, those measures to remove the
people who wash that they do so, but not to
determine that due to a situation of a
rite it is that they can put  the
mexican team at risk and that the dif family
concacaf and the mexican
soccer federation come together to motivate the
fans to stop saying this on
the pitches yell at them all you
want
- the yell that leaves us out of the game
During the final of the League of Nations,
the game was interrupted as a first
notice and part of the protocol in the face of an
anti-disciplinary attitude.
Mexico will now participate in the Gold Cup,
meanwhile, its players insist  sten in
that the fans enjoy the game
without having to work the rival reported
for them nao in Spanish
natalia lanzelotti